Okay.
We now have the first major election forecast
for Biden versus Trump in November.
And it tells us exactly what I told you last
week, which is that Donald Trump can easily
win this election.
I'm talking about the 538 forecast, which
sort of synthesizes all the polling information
at the national and state level, combines
it with historical data, combines it with
other factors.
It's all analyzed and outcomes, a number that
tells us how likely is it that Trump will
win and how likely is it that Joe Biden will
win.
And these numbers are then up to us to interpret.
In this case, the numbers are that 538 gives
Joe Biden a 71 percent chance of winning.
And it gives Donald Trump a 29 percent chance
of winning.
Now.
Careful.
If you believe this is accurate, it is way
too close to think that anything is remotely
certain in this election, 71 to 29.
In practical terms is 50 50 now.
I want people to really understand the math
of this.
What this means is that if you were to run
100 elections with today's inputs, today's
inputs in seventy one of those hundred elections,
Joe Biden would win.
And in twenty nine of those hundred elections,
Donald Trump would win.
If nothing changes.
Now, of course, if anything changes between
now and November in the direction of Trump,
that 29 percent number goes up.
But forget about that.
Twenty nine percent is really, really high.
I mean, just apply it to your life.
Does anybody get on a plane if there's a 29
percent chance of a problem with the plane's
flight worthiness?
Of course not.
Does anybody go to a dentist and you have
them fix a cavity?
If there is a 29 percent chance they make
a mistake, you would never go to that dentist
more trivially.
I don't take a sip of water if I think there
is a two point nine percent chance the water
is tainted.
Never mind.
Twenty nine percent.
So for all intents and purposes, in terms
of our behavior.
Twenty nine percent is like 50/50.
And if you need any more convincing about
that, when announcing the forecast, Nate Silver
from 538 actually said, coincidentally, these
are the exact same odds as in our final forecast
in 2016, which was Clinton 71 percent chance
to win, Trump 29 percent.
Now, if you want to, do, you know, a little
bit of multiplication.
The odds of Trump winning twice in a row with
29 percent likelihood is about eight percent.
This is like flipping a coin.
If you flip a coin once, the odds of heads
are 50 percent.
If after that first flip, you flip it a second
time.
The odds of heads on that one flip are still
50 percent.
But if in advance I say to you, what are the
odds of heads twice in a row?
You multiply point five times, point five,
and you get 25 percent.
Similarly, if Trump's odds really were twenty
nine percent in 2016 and they're 29 percent
now in the abstract, the odds of winning twice
with 29 percent odds are about eight percent.
But it doesn't matter.
It's 29 percent right now.
It's essentially a coin flip from the standpoint
of how we should behave.
Just vote.
Guys, that's it.
And this reinforces, you know, when you see
Biden plus twelve, you might get the impression
that we should be thinking about this differently.
It's 50/50.
This is a critical moment.
This is not a rehearsal.
Let's not mess this up